event is about as you know uh the
Simon's Institute hosts thematic
programs every semester on a wide range
of topics and associated with each
program
um there are many research fellows we
can be post docs Junior faculty
elsewhere sometimes senior students and
in addition to that we also have running
pods and Quantum Computing and machine
learning which has their own
postdoctoral fellows as well so put all
this together the Simon's Institute uh
is lucky to have probably the largest
concentration of uh postdocs in
theoretical computer science broadly
construed all converging at one place at
any given time so and in fact uh the
research fellows are in some sense the
one of The Shining jewels of these
programs because they really have a lot
of energy they're you know brimming with
ideas push to Frontiers
um as you can imagine and we uh one of
the things we do at the beginning of
each semester is to have this event
where we invite the fellows in the
program and any other fellows longer
term to give talks on their research and
the idea is the talks are brief so the
idea is it's more like an icebreaker so
you learn a little bit about what they
are interested in they can
um you know and some of the talks could
even be invitations to collaborate or
you know open problems the format is up
to them and uh we have an exciting uh
um schedule of talks today um so the
program is a little bit shorter this
semester because we have only one
program running currently in meta
complexity
um so we will wrap this up in the
morning session normally it's an all day
or even a longer than a day event
um so we have two sessions today um the
first session with five talks and the
second session with four talks and um so
let's get uh started uh with the first
talk by you all done on adversarial laws
of large numbers and connections to
online classifications
okay uh yeah
okay yeah uh so yeah this is more like
uh statistics or like a learning theory
uh topic so I'll talk about and it's
connected to also streaming algorithm so
talk about a specific work uh it's
called the adversarial a lot of large
numbers
a collaboration with the Noka alone
you give
so uh I will talk about three things so
first of all I will talk about an online
sampling setting uh where there is some
sampler that is competing against an
adversary
then I will talk about online learning
and I will talk about the connection
between these two settings
so the motivation here is that we have a
very large amount of data
and like a stream of data and there is
an algorithm that doesn't have resources
uh to see all the data
so they can just see a small fraction of
the data and they want to analyze the
whole stream using only their subset for
example maybe you have an internet
adapter that gets a lot of traffic data
and they want to analyze what's
happening in the network but they can
only sample small fraction of it and
analyze it
um
so uh here is like the algorithm that
we're going to analyze
so we have a stream of data points and
there is an uh algorithm that decides
for each data point if they want to
store or discard the point so they're
going to store every Point independently
with uh some small probability p and
then otherwise discard it and the
algorithm only has access to the points
that they sampled
foreign
and now uh before describing the
adversarial setting that I'm going to
discuss let me first uh compare it to
the classical assumption this assumption
was used to analyze a classical
streaming algorithms and this assumption
assumes that the stream of examples is
fixed ahead of time
so there is maybe the stream the order
of the elements in the Stream can be
adverse adversarial but the classical
assumption was that the algorithm cannot
interact with the Stream So the elements
were fixed but this assumption is not
realistic
uh because the algorithm can interact
with the stream for example you have an
online store and you want to analyze it
so you analyze the stream by collecting
statistics but then after analyzing the
string maybe you change your inventory
change your prices and thereby you
affect interact with the Stream
and uh there are many other examples so
we want to have a different notion of
stream that is a adverse area and this
was suggested by Ben and Edwin and you
give
so here there is an adversary that
generates a stream
and in this setting we assume that the
adversary knows everything about the
algorithm so the adversary knows the
internal state of the algorithm
and in this talk this will correspond to
the adversary knowing exactly what
points were sampled
so the adversary will start by
generating the first point
and then they see if this point was
sampled and based on that they generated
they decide what is the second element
in the Stream
etc etc
so the adversary knows exactly what was
sampled and they change they adapt the
stream based on uh whatever was sampled
and uh here is the
so so now we have as we defined the
adversarial stream and now uh I'll
explain to you what is the goal uh what
is the algorithmic task that we want to
solve in in this work
um so here we have multiple statistics
of the Stream So each statistic is just
like a statistic function and we want to
know the average of each of these
functions on the Stream
but we only have access to to a sample
so we will just analyze an algorithm
that is Computing the average of each
function on the sample and we'll use it
to approximate the average on the whole
stream
and our goal is to uh get all these
functions correctly so we have like a
class of functions and our error will be
the maximum over all the functions of
the difference between uh the average on
the stream and the average on the sample
and uh why is this maximum an important
notion uh for example maybe you want to
run some algorithms that uses all these
statistics and even if you get one
statistic wrong you can fail the
algorithm uh for example like you want
to Route cars over some Network like you
have your GPS system you want to Route
cars and if you get if you if there is
one congested Network that you make a
mistake there then maybe you can you're
going to send all the cars over there
and you are screwed so like in many
cases you really want to get all the
statistics correctly
so this is the task and
and our goal would be uh so we want
a sample such that for all the
statistics and the error is going to be
bounded by Epsilon and this is with
probability one minus Delta and the
probability is taken over the randomness
of the algorithm
and so first let me describe some prior
works so first of all uh in the
classical assumption that the stream is
fixed the answer is very easy so we want
to know like how how big should the
sample be and in the classical
assumption the length of the of the
sample
corresponds to the VC dimension of the
class of functions and the VC Dimension
is like is a combinatorial property of
the class of functions that is used for
learning theory and this follows
directly
from the fundamental theorem of fact
learning
and now for adversarial stream uh
Benedict and you give showed that the
visit I mentioned might not suffice and
they also showed an upper bound that
depends on the law of cardinality of the
class of functions
but now the question is what happens if
the cluster functions is very large or
infinite maybe we can get a better
dependency so we want a smaller sample
in general and in this work we show that
uh the sample size that you need is up
to constant factors uh the little Stone
dimension of the class of function that
we want to approximate
and here a little Stone Dimension is uh
essentially another combinatorial
property of the class of functions and
this captures the error in online
learning
essentially uh so we shall we connect
the sample complexity to a different
quantity that is called little Stone's
dimension
of the class of function
and uh as an application of of the proof
uh we also show an optimal Bound for
online learning and uh
uh here we essentially we improve a
logarithmic factor for learning with
their one losses
so uh how many minutes do I have left
54 minutes okay
uh so let me explain briefly about about
the proof
so uh and and I want to explain how the
adversarial sampling connects to online
learning
so there is this notion of sequential
random Market complexity
that it was defined by Russ
and this notion they show that it bounds
the regret in online learning like the
error on learning and they got a bound
on this notion the sequential of the
muscle complexity if you are familiar
it's an analog of the radomatic
complexity that is used in classical
learning to the online learning setting
and in this work uh we bound the error
in sampling by the sequential random
machine complexity and we get a tighter
bound on the sequential complexity
and thereby we also improve the balance
for for on an earth
uh and now let me explain to you like
what are the main like proof ideas uh
so first of all uh I want to uh explain
how the sample complexity is bounded by
the sequential radar complexity so let
me tell you uh what is the sequential
rather complexity so essentially the
sequential random complexity is
equivalent to uh the the
error in adversarial sampling
where you sample each element with
probability one-half
so in the original problem we sampled
each element with a very small
probability because we have a really
small sample compared to the large
stream
but here we want to reduce from a very
tiny sampling probability to a sampling
probability of one-half
and uh
the way you do it is you look at another
what is called like a ghost sample
so uh and this another sample you draw
it for the analysis and then you compare
uh the true sample to the gold sample
and uh
by some simple reductions we can show
that it's sufficient to bound the true
sample to the goal sample and then we
can ignore the rest of the stream and we
have a much smaller stream where the
sample is just a half
a half of the smaller string
uh
and and now we reduce the sampling
problem to the problem where you sample
everything with probability one-half
which is also corresponding to the
sequential of the machine complexity
and now in order to bound the sequential
rather complexity
so what people usually do they use the
notion of what is called covering
numbers
so covering number is the smallest side
of an Epsilon net on the class of
functions
and in the online setting it was very uh
in the adversarial setting it's hard to
get good bounce on the covering numbers
so here we show a relaxation of the
covering numbers which is like
fractional cover so we have a
distribution
over over cover elements
and uh with this relaxation we can get
better bounce
so
so these are the like the main main
proof ideas
uh so now let me summarize so
I explained uh the adversarial streaming
model
where uh you compete with an adversary
rather than a stream that is uh fixed
ahead of time
and the goal is to approximate multiple
statistic functions
and here we showed uh what is the
optimal sample size and we also got a
tight bounce for online learning
and uh for the proof so we show how to
reduce to the notion of sequential by
the muscle complexity
and we use a notion of a fractional
covering numbers rather than the
classical covering numbers and uh also
there are some open problems for example
we can look at weaker adversarial models
maybe models were the adversary doesn't
know everything about you maybe the
adversary will know less and you want to
compete with with them and we can think
of either sampling tasks maybe you want
to compute some more complicated
functions of of the Stream
and maybe get and there are other other
programs one can think
time for maybe a quick question yeah
find a class of statistical tasks that
your result applies to
can you repeat the question
yeah it's a it's a class with a zero one
function like the environment zero and
one it can be in any class uh
yeah vessels yeah they're one fraction
and because you are competing against an
adversary so the notion of a
a little some Dimension characterize
this exactly what is the temperature
that you need against an Optima against
the best adverse essential against the
words
um thanks again and uh next stop
your next talk is quantum for science by
Jin Peng Liu